hello
humans and other carbon-based life forms
it's me dave rubin and this is the
reuben report direct message
for today october 14 2020 and don't
worry people there's no shortage of
things to talk about
i don't know if you heard about this but
there is a confirmation hearing
for a supreme court justice and the
senators just made complete fools of
themselves
we're only going to show one clip though
because i don't want to bludgeon you
with clips of ridiculous pompous
self-serving senators
making fools of themselves so i only
picked one i picked the most special
of all the clips so we're going to talk
about that
then we are going to talk about a video
that was going viral
last night that you are not going to see
on mainstream media there
there is a rather incredible video uh of
a young black man on a southwest
flight from last night i think it's from
yesterday afternoon actually the video
went viral
a little later in the evening uh and
he's being kicked off the flight because
he was eating with his mask down now
you're allowed to eat with your mask
down you're allowed to drink with your
mask down et cetera et cetera
but you might find this part interesting
uh he had a trump 2020 mask
and he had a black voices for trump hat
do you think that might have had
something to do with it
he was then kicked off by uh by a white
employee of southwest and the woman
videotaping it was actually
traveling with him uh she teaches
constitution all over the country they
were traveling he was doing some video
work for her and they were traveling
to talk about the constitution together
i actually
just interviewed them a little bit
before we're taping this
i got assurances from them that nothing
that you don't see in the video happened
that would have been warranted
to allow them to be kicked off so i
interviewed both of them
it's just about a 12 minute or so
interview that i think you guys will
find really interesting and
the reason i wanted to do it of course
is because we know
that if a young black man was kicked off
a flight
in normal circumstances this is the type
of story that the media would say we're
systemically racist this is racism
southwest is racist everyone should be
fired et cetera et cetera
but because he was wearing a trump mask
and a black voices for trump hats
somehow
i'm guessing this ain't going to be on
cnn today this ain't going to be on
msnbc
and thus it leaves dave rubin to have to
tell you stories of things that you
should know about because
as i keep saying to you guys one type of
fake news
is the stuff that they won't show you
because it doesn't fit the narrative so
i had a really interesting
interview with philip who's the young
man and the woman that he was traveling
with
uh and then the third story i wanted to
do today is actually not current events
you know i
always tell you guys i don't want you
guys to just be obsessed with current
events i don't want to be obsessed with
current events
but sometimes something comes across my
desk that feels right for the moment
that doesn't have anything to do with
necessarily what's happening
today and yesterday i saw a video
posted by rita panahi who's an
australian journalist
uh who i've had on the show and i've
been on her show when i was in australia
and she's one of the
really really great she's a journalist
she's an actual journalist who i don't
have to put air quotes around when i say
journalism that's
that's the best thing i can say about a
journalist but she she retweeted a video
uh that was originally from firing line
which was an interview show
decades ago and there's an interview
with former british prime minister
margaret
thatcher and in this two-minute
interview which we're going to show you
the clip of
she talks about how the labor movement
which in effect is sort of our
democratic party here
uh in america so meaning our left how it
sort of
always gets led by its worst elements
and that how a small group
of people can sort of expand and keep
everybody
in a constant state of fear and that's
why the thing gets so out of control and
i was watching it going yes
this is literally exactly what i've been
saying about our democratic party
and why the good democrats have nothing
to do to stand up or they just have no
ability basically to stand up
against the radical left elements and
the progressives and the marxists
and the rest and the rest of it uh but
before we get to that
i wanted to tell you guys a little bit
about ancestry.com you know all about
them
but there are many paths to finding your
family's story whichever way you choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree or uncovering your
ethnicity with ancestry dna
is easy to get started with ancestry
an ancestry dna test tells you where
your ancestors are from
and ancestry's billions of records and
millions of family trees let you
discover their personal stories
you could find a famous relative or
perhaps a photo of your great grandma as
a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history and yourself
after all the story of your family is
the story of you
researching your history is a fun
activity for the whole family and the
stories you learn about your
shared past can bring you closer
together ancestry dna can reveal
ethnic origins and provide historical
details that bring your unique family
story to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint the specific regions within
them
giving you insightful geographic detail
about your history
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family moved
from place to place around the world
no other dna test delivers such a unique
interactive experience
it's easy to start making discoveries
with ancestry grab an ancestry dna kit
and start a free trial to amplify
your discoveries with ancestry's
billions of records
start exploring your family story today
head to my url
ancestry.com ruben to get your ancestry
dna kit
and start your free trial that's
ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me all right here
we go people uh the big story of course
of the day
certainly of yesterday and it's gonna
roll into today and finish up throughout
the week
uh is the the confirmation hearings of
amy coney barrett now
on the broad side of this first off i
don't expect all of you guys to be
watching all of these things i'm amazed
you know
one of the problems we have right now is
because so many of us are trapped at
home and we're working from home
you've got people good people who have
lives and children and should be out
doing things and talking to other people
and being productive and instead they're
watching c-span all day i mean watching
confirmation hearings for a supreme
court justice that's not to
diminish the importance of a supreme
court justice
or even of a hearing even though we know
the outcome of the hearing already right
like again the republicans have
the votes this woman is being confirmed
as a supreme court judge so everything
you're watching when cory booker is
crying
and everything else it's all theater
that doesn't diminish the important
issues that they're sort of
talking about but there's there's a lot
of just sort of drivel
and theater and the fact that everyone
is just watching this thing for hours
like you don't need to watch it for
hours
if you could just get little little
bites you can get a flavor
of what's going on in the country and
uh and and sort of what the important
issues are that we're talking about
in any event my my bumper sticker review
of what's been going on
is that she is absolutely an excellent
candidate
she will she will
let's put it this way she will be
looking at the constitution not
as as i said to you guys yesterday as
she wants it to be but as it was written
and that's
how she will make her judicial decisions
i think that's the best thing you can
ask
for these people you don't want judges
legislating from the bench you want them
analyzing the law
as it is so beyond that she also strikes
me as
a pretty decent human being i think she
has seven uh children two of them
adopted from haiti which
we would have thought was a good thing
until the last week or so when
some crazy radical leftists have been
saying it's because she's a colonizer or
something like that
but she seems like a good family person
there's the wonderful moment yesterday
where she holds up her notes
and she's got nothing there and all the
senators have essays and books and
all this stuff in front of them she
seems totally competent and all of those
things and
even john king on cnn yesterday
said that in normal times this is
someone who would get something like 70
votes she's basically going to get 51
because unfortunately it's going to be
on partisan
lines which is a much bigger topic to
talk about relative to just how
everything is sort of devolved into
republican
versus democrat anyway there was a bunch
of viral videos yesterday
of the senators asking her sort of
ridiculous questions cory booker
literally almost as he was crying like
this overly emotive
thing asking her if she's a white
supremacist
and he basically said he had to ask her
because our president
won't deny white supremacist uh white
supremacism i mean it's just
it's just so stupid so much of it but i
thought the stupidest
it wasn't cory booker the stupidest one
was senator mazzy hirono she is from
hawaii
and uh well let's just go to the
videotape
to ensure the fitness of nominees for a
lifetime appointment to the federal
bench or to any of the
other positions for any of the
committees on which they appear
i ask each nominee these two questions
and i will ask them of you
since you became a legal adult have you
ever made
unwanted requests for sexual favors or
committed any verbal or physical
harassment or assault over sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct no
senator
judge barrett do you think it is
appropriate for
justices to consider real world impacts
in their
decision making as justice ginsburg
noted in a number of her descents
okay so to be clear as to what just
happened there
mazzy just asked a woman who has never
been accused of sexual favors or
committing any verbal or physical
harassment or assault of anyone
in a sexual nature of otherwise if she's
done
any of that stuff now mazzy's saying
this is what she asks everybody but just
this type of stupidity
it's just theater for the clique
for the moment that can possibly go
viral
for it to get listed in twitter's trends
so that someone out there will somehow
associate
amy coney barrett with sexual favors
or physical or sexual harassment or
something like that and it's
just nonsense again she is going
to be confirmed there's really no
argument against whether she should be
confirmed or not now what you could say
what a lot of the democrats were doing
yesterday was
they were saying well you know you might
flip
uh roe v wade which again it's very
important to say this because people are
very confused as to what roe v wade is
roe v wade did not make abortion legal
what it did was it took it out of the
states and it made it federally legal
right so before that the states all made
their own decision
um so as a as a small government guy and
someone that believes in federalism for
me
even though as many of you know and by
the way many of you criticized me for
i lay out an uh a begrudgingly
pro-choice argument in my book which is
that in the first trimester you leave it
up to the woman and
i lay out all the reasons for that and
i'm and i'm more than happy to continue
that discussion
and and disagree with some of you guys
on that that's just fine
um but what the what the democratic
senators were doing
basically were saying well if you want
to reverse that then you you are not
qualified and that's not first off she
can't pre-judge a case right there's no
case on the way up
that would even get it there now there
could be in the future but she can't
pre-judge a case so they're trying to
get her to pre-judge a case
um and so that in and of itself is bad
but also
the idea that just because a case just
because there's a a decision that has
been made in the past the roe v wade
decision
just because the decision has been made
in the past that a judge
isn't allowed to potentially disagree
with the decision
that that doesn't really make sense so
the two they were trying to get her on
basically the implication was you hate
women because you're going to want to
flip roe v wade even though
she has not said that and that she will
further dismantle obamacare the
affordable care act
even though she has not specifically
said that and and of course will there
be cases that get up to the supreme
court
about the affordable care act of course
there will but also it's
it's extremely important to remember
guys and don't forget this
that judges sometimes who are brought in
and thought of as conservative
end up doing things that are not
conservative and judges who are thought
of as liberal
end up doing things that are not thought
of as liberal right i mean this
this happened when obamacare was passed
in the first place with john roberts so
these things
do happen but the the the bumper sticker
as i said before
is that she is going to be confirmed
she strikes i think pretty much
everybody as a decent person and just
watching unfortunately
the democrats you know are you a white
supremacist
have you ever sexually assaulted anyone
it's like man
you guys really blew your load with
brett kavanaugh you went
all in on trying to destroy a human
being with brett kavanaugh
and now this is what you're left with
you're left with nothing you're left
with
knowing that you're holding a farce
hearing because she's going to be
confirmed
and the fact that you're just throwing
out crazy nonsense
because because you've got nothing left
to do all right guys before we move to
the second story
i want to talk about second thoughts the
board game
i'm even holding it up right that's
pretty good uh this game is seriously
seriously fun and i'm not just saying it
and
uh the makers of the game are are fans
of the show
uh so i'm thrilled that they're that
they're supporting us here
guys second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that'll be sure to
be a hit
with your friends and family on game
night the play of the game calls for
each team to quickly create a list of
words for their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious
puzzlement and laughter simply put it's
a classical
word guessing game with a unique twist
that allows players to personalize the
content
with their voluminous sense of word
smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious
high speed attempt to stump the other
team both teams create a list
of five things using the letters
revealed from the color
dice be witty and wise but don't take
too long because time is not on your
side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents get to guess them
second thoughts the quick thinking
versus fast talking party game
how am i doing on fast talking not too
bad get yours today at second thoughts
the game dot com that's second thoughts
the game dot com or at your local target
store
and now back to me doing the show all
right here we go
so the next story that i want to cover
today is this
this viral video that hopefully you've
seen already
uh and as i mentioned in uh in about an
hour or so from posting this we are
going to post an interview with
uh the guy that you're gonna see here in
this viral video and the woman who
videotaped it
this is video from a southwest airlines
flight from yesterday
where a young black man who he just
happens to be black okay
uh he is uh he's eating
some nuts i think it is he's eating some
nuts and i think he had a cup of coffee
on a southwest flight and he was kicked
off a flight
the flight attendant reported that he
wasn't wearing his mask
and the next thing you know you've got
you know the higher up at southwest
they're kicking them off
the guy happens to be white that's
kicking him off he happens to be black
i don't really care about the racial
element of any of this
except that the little asterisk
to the story is that he had a trump 2020
mask and a young
and a black voice is for trump uh hat
and now we know this does not
fit the narrative right this doesn't fit
the narrative of racism because somehow
if you're
black and you're a trump supporter then
nothing is racist but we know if he
wasn't a trump supporter then everything
is racist
i mean it's the same old silly nonsense
so we are going
to post an uh an interview it's a very
short interview i wanted to get their
feelings about what happened because it
wasn't going to be covered by mainstream
we're going to post that interview in
about an hour but here's just a portion
of the of the viral video
can you tell us the policy that prevents
him from taking his mask off while he's
eating please
he's an attorney i was not i was not
here for president the crew has denied
okay but you're seeing him with eating
so please tell me the policy tell the
crew to tell me the policy
that says he cannot eat with his mask
off right now
here you go he put his mask on he took
it off when he started eating the nuts
that was good
okay so do you follow your policy
indiscriminately and impartially or do
you just do this for people whose
message you don't like
okay so just to be clear again uh when i
talked
to philip and uh and the lady who uh
videotaped that they have assured me
that he was not doing anything
untoward he had not gotten into a fight
or anything else before that
and i will give you one other little uh
preview of the interview
which is that they're not looking to sue
they want to find out what happened
they'd like to get down to the end of it
actually
the woman filming they were they were
traveling because uh she teaches the
constitution
to to various groups throughout the
country and he was doing some video work
for her so these are not people i mean i
think
you'll see when you see the interview
philip this is not a guy that was
looking for publicity and you can even
see it
you can even see it in that video right
like we see other videos
of people going bananas on planes and
screaming at people and everything else
because
they just want attention and this
clearly was not the case with the guy so
that'll
that'll be up in about an hour and i
just want to cover uh one other thing
today and this is not
pure current events um but i did see a
video that was
uh shared by rita panahi who as i
mentioned is a is a journalist
in australia an actual journalist and it
was a video from firing line which was
an old interview show
back in the day and they had interviewed
margaret thatcher who's the former prime
minister
of england and i thought what she said
in this interview from about three
decades ago is so
applicable to what is happening with the
democrats and the left of today so let's
take a look
in 1959 you could count the number of
extreme left wingers in the labour party
certainly on two hands
there are perhaps seven or eight of them
we knew who they were we all rather
thought that this was just an example of
the eccentricity of british politics
that that allowed that kind of thing
it was yes yes and in a way it was
rather proud that this thing happened
now after the last election there are
more than 80
of them so you see you've gone from a
situation in which you had a
very few left wingers in the labour
party the one in which you've had
over 80. doesn't that argue against no
no no one moment
i haven't even developed the thesis yet
now you know you've traveled the world
as i have
the one thing about left-wing
politicians is they're always fanatical
they never let go it's their religion
they go on
and on and although they are a minority
of the labour party about 80 to 100 out
of some 300
they tend to dominate them in view it's
the left wing
that i think has led the policies of the
labour party
and your social democrats have not
really argued with them although they've
been in the majority
they've not been in the ascendancy okay
so what she's describing there i mean
man
doesn't that sound exactly like what has
happened
with the democrats right that there was
this like small
loud contingency and then it started
getting bigger
and then sort of the old school
democrats just withered beneath it i
mean that that's
almost everything that i've been talking
about for the last couple of years and
how
the the good liberals whatever the
remaining old-school
good liberals are the the liberals who
don't want the government
to do everything who don't think
everything is racist who don't
want to burn everything down they seem
to have no defense
against the radical new progressive
marxist lefties right they have
no defense against the aocs and the
ilhan omars it's not because the aocs
and the ilhan omars
have better ideas it's because they bark
loudly and they call everybody racist
and and
the liberals unfortunately they they
cower
in the name of that and that's why so
many of the liberal
institutions are crumbling because once
you basically say hey however you feel
about something
is just as important as what the truth
might be well then everyone can come in
with whatever
their crazy theory of the day is and
then you'll watch
all of the institutions burn so the line
that i really thought was great there
uh is thatcher saying the one thing with
left-wing politicians
is that they're fanatical it's their
religion
and we've talked about this a bunch on
the show and i often quote my
my friend and former guest peter
bogosian uh who has talked about
wokism as a secular religion
meaning they've thrown away all rel all
other religious belief
all belief outside of themselves right
and what they believe in
is that they can create a world through
laws
through creating a system that they
install who is more powerful
than who and who can take and who can
give and all of those things that
they can create a system that that they
they don't need religion it's
it's their it's their philosophical
worldview of everything this is also
partly why
why generally right now and i see this
consistently
is that people on the left seem to be
far more hysterical
and angry and and mean
really than people on the right and and
there's a fundamental reasoning for that
and the reasoning is they've
they've traded in any other belief for
the belief in the system that they can
create and that that is a type of
religious
thinking now in most religions you have
some sort of redemption narrative right
there's some sort of forgiveness
that you can do but but actually in this
new woke religion
especially if you are a white
heterosexual
uh christian man you have to bow forever
and i don't know about you guys out
there but i
refuse to to live by
someone else's rules and bow to them
forever
and that's why the the walk away
movement meaning the people that are
leaving the left
and it doesn't mean you're a
card-carrying republican necessarily but
the people who are going oh you know
those conservatives they ain't so bad
those libertarians they ain't so bad
something interesting is happening in
this in this trump space and as you guys
know i just stumbled upon a trump rally
the other day and it was absolutely
incredible there was no racist
there or anything else like that um you
can see why the walk away movement
is is picking up so much momentum um
and and the blexit movement and the rest
of it you can see it because young
people are going wait a minute wait a
minute
when did being on the left which used to
be about
free speech and it used to be cool and
and artists why were artists and
musicians and comedians and all of the
all the things that make up culture why
were they all lefties because the left
used to be the home for free expression
but as they've become religious in
nature which is exactly
what margaret thatcher is talking about
they've tried to stifle dissent show me
where there's a healthy
debate of ideas where there's healthy
dissent uh
on the left it basically does not
exist which is partly also why joe biden
seems incapable
of of answering a question honestly
about what he thinks about anything
because he knows his own base
will destroy him and again that is not
to say people like that reuben you
become such a trump
blah blah blah you went from being on
the left and now you're just a
conservative or something like that
and it's like okay if being
gay married and pro-choice and against
the death penalty
if all of that fits within the
conservative tent
um or the the tent on the right well
that's a much better place to be because
we can all agree to disagree
and the rest of it and i'm not trying to
convince anyone that i'm right on all of
the issues i wrote a whole
a whole book about it you don't have to
agree with me about all of this stuff
um but i know that a certain set of
people are willing to talk about it
while a certain set of people have
become
fanatical and religious in their belief
anyway i thought the clip was worth
playing because not only
was this roughly 30 years ago that
margaret thatcher was talking about it
but she was obviously talking about it
uh you know with uh within the lens of
what was happening politically in
england and it's like you know for
everybody that wakes up and thinks oh
this is so unique what's happening right
now is just so unique it's never
happened before and it'll never happen
again and it's the worst
time ever well these things are cyclical
and they happen before it happened
with the labor party and by the way look
at the labor party in the uk right now
it was completely destroyed
by the radical leftists right the jeremy
corbyn left
was crushed in the elections and and my
hope is that that is what will happen
with the democrats this time because
then maybe they can recalibrate and some
old school democrats some blue dog
democrats some
some decent open-minded free speech
democrats could come back
and then guess what as as jordan
peterson always says you would then have
a healthy tension
between the left and the right a healthy
tension between democrats and
conservatives a healthy tension between
conservatives and liberals all right
people the interview
uh that i did with uh the young man and
the lady
uh from southwest flight that we just
showed you the video that'll be up in
about an hour
this has been the reuben report direct
message have a nice day everybody
and uh take a walk how about taking a
walk get out there
and get a little sunshine all right see
you guys tomorrow